let us now examine what conditional
probabilities are good for we have
already discussed that they are used to
revise a model when we get new
information but there is another way in
which they arise we can use conditional
probabilities to build a multistage
model of a probabilistic experiment we
will illustrate this through an example
involving the detection of an object up
in the sky by a radar we will keep our
example very simple on the other hand it
turns out to have all the basic elements
of a real-world model so we are looking
up in the sky
and either there's an airplane flying up
there or not let us call event a the
event that an airplane is indeed flying
up there and we have two possibilities
either event a occurs or the complement
of a occurs in which case nothing is
flying up there we also at this point we
can also assign some probabilities to
these two possibilities let us say that
through prior experience perhaps or some
other knowledge we know that the
probability that something is indeed
flying up there is 5% and with
probability 95% nothing is flying now we
also have a radar that looks up there
and there are two things that can happen
either something registers on the radar
screen or nothing registers of course if
it's a good radar probably event B will
tend to go together with event K but
it's also possible that the radar will
make some mistakes and so we have
various possibilities if there is a
plane up there it's possible that the
radar will detect it in which case event
B will also happen but it's also
conceivable that the radar will not
detect it in which case we have a
so-called miss and so a plane is flying
up there but the radar means
it did not detect it another possibility
is that nothing is flying up there but
the radar does detect something and this
is a situation that's called a false
alarm finally there's the possibility
that nothing is flying up there and the
Raider did not see anything either now
let us focus on this particular
situation suppose that event a has
occurred so we are living inside this
particular universe in this universe
there are two possibilities and we can
assign probabilities to these two
possibilities so let's say that if
something is flying up there our radar
will find it with probability 99% but
we'll also miss it with probability one
percent what's the meaning of this
number
99% well this is a probability that
applies to a situation where an airplane
is up there so it is really a
conditional probability
it's the conditional probability that we
will detect something the radar will
detect the plane given that the plane is
already flying up there and similarly
this 1% can be thought of as the
conditional probability that the
complement of B occurs so the radar
doesn't see anything given that there is
a plane up in the sky we can assign
similar probabilities to and the other
under the other scenario if there is no
plane there is a probability that there
will be a false alarm and there is a
probability that the Raider will not see
anything those four numbers here are in
essence the specs of our radar they
describe how the radar behaves in a
world in which an airplane has been
placed in the sky and some other numbers
that describe how the radar behaves in a
world where nothing is flying
up in the sky so we have described
various probabilistic properties of our
model but is it a complete model can we
calculate anything that we might wish to
calculate let us look at this question
can we calculate the probability that
both a and B occur it's this particular
scenario here how can we calculate it
well let us remember the definition of
conditional probabilities the pro'
conditional probability of an event
given another event is the probability
of their intersection divided by the
probability of the conditioning event
but this doesn't quite help us because
we if we try to calculate the numerator
we do not have the value of the
probability of a given B we have the
value of the probability of B given a
what can we do well we notice that we
can use this definition of conditional
probabilities but use it in the reverse
direction interchanging the roles of a
and B if we interchange the roles of a
and B our definition leads to the
following expression the conditional
probability of B given a is the
probability that both events occur
divided by the probability again of the
conditioning event therefore the
probability that a and B occur is equal
to the probability that a occurs times
the conditional probability that B
occurs given that a occurred and in our
example this is point zero five times
the conditional probability that B
occurs which is 0.99 so we can calculate
the probability of this particular event
by multiplying probabilities and
conditional probabilities along the path
in this tree diagram that leads us here
and we can do the same for any other
leaf in this diagram so for example the
probability that this happens is going
to be the probability of this event
times the conditional probability of B
complement given that a complement has
occurred how about a different question
what is the probability the total
probability that the radar sees
something let us try to identify this
event the radar can see something under
two scenarios there is the scenario
where there is a plate up in the sky and
the radar sees it and there is another
scenario where nothing is up in the sky
but the radar thinks that it sees
something so these two possibilities
together make up the event B and so to
calculate the probability of B we need
to add the probabilities of these two
events for the first event we already
calculated it its 0.05 times 0.99 for
the second possibility we need to do a
similar calculation the probability that
this occurs is equal to 0.95 times the
conditional probability of B occurring
under the scenario where a complement
has occurred and this is 0.1 if we add
those two numbers together the answer
turns out to be zero point one four four
five finally last question which is
perhaps the most interesting one suppose
that the radar registered something what
is the probability that there is an
airplane out there how do we do this
calculation well we can start from the
definition of condition of the
conditional probability of a given B
and note that we already have in our
hands both the numerator and the
denominator so the numerator is this
number 0.05 times 0.99 and the
denominator is zero one four four five
and we can use our calculators to see
that the answer is approximately zero
point three four so there is a thirty
four percent probability that an
airplane is there
given that the red that the radar has
seen or thinks that it sees something so
it's the numerical value of this answer
is somewhat interesting because it's
pretty small even though we have a very
good radar that tells us the right thing
99 percent of the time under one
scenario and ninety percent under the
under scenario despite that given that
the radar has seen something this is not
really convincing or compelling evidence
that there is an airplane up there the
probability that there's an airplane up
there is only thirty four percent in a
situation where the radar thinks that it
has seen something so in the next few
segments we are going to revisit these
three calculations and see how they can
generalize in fact a large part of what
is to happen in the remainder of this
class will be elaboration on these three
ideas there are three types of
calculations that will show up over and
over of course in more complicated forms
but the basic ideas are essentially
captured in this simple example